hallo da bist du herzlich willkommen wie
heute zu einem neuen video ich habe mir
einen chemiebaukasten geholt und mit dem
machen wir heute sehr viel schwachsinn
ich weiß nicht was man damit alles
machen kann und das gefährde hier so gar
nicht ob das rumspricht etwas kleckern
kaputtgeht keine ahnung ich kenne jetzt
auf jeden fall ist meinen kompletten
schreibtisch mit zeitungspapier aus sie
mir sicherheits klamotten an und setzt
mich jetzt hin
hallo und herzlich willkommen ich habe
mir einen kittel angezogen da vorne bei
der marke drauf aber ich etwas abgeklebt
mit papier
das ist sowohl ich habe unter dem titel
nichts an und hat auch noch ein weißes
t-shirt vorgezogen weil ich nicht weiß
wie ihr irgendwie was kaputt gehen wird
explodieren keine ahnung ist es nämlich
überhaupt kein placement irgendwie für
galileo oder soll sich welche für gott
nicht bezahlt ab heilige scheiße nur ein
paar sekunden später von bisschen ein
ovaler beccarelli
albert einstein oder stolz auf mich wie
albert einstein chemiker sondern
physiker locker wir haben uns heute
allerdings nicht versammelt um ich kann
hier durch dann toll habe ich die brille
auch schon kaputt gemacht diese brille
hat mich so ein bisschen an die
taucherbrille die müssen nicht bei der
fussball challenge aufgezogen hatten die
fußballer in spanien weil hier irgendwo
ein sehr witziges video achtung nicht
der einen für kinder unter 8 jahren
wieso hole ich mir den will ich das gar
nicht machen da wir lesen uns natürlich
super lange die ganzen anleitungen
hierdurch was wir alles drin haben sind
alter schwede ich will ich nicht sagen
aber da stehen so total viele
gefahrenhinweise drauf mit irgendwelchen
ausrufezeichen und umweltverschmutzung
sit und ich denke ich kann ihr durch
nicht sehen die chance besteht die kunst
ich hab die kameraposition jetzt mal
kurz ferner war das so doch ein bisschen
entspannter zum zuschauen ist glaube ich
wir haben in diesem karton verschiedene
sachen drin ich kann dich nicht sehen
mit dieser brille leid es mir tut die
brille ist verurteilt und die lacht
richter wahrscheinlich gerade total
drüber wenn ich dadurch nicht sehen kann
ist natürlich auch irgendwie
kontraproduktiv ich habe jetzt erst mal
die komplette scheiße raus geräumt die
custom auf dem cover t nicht mehr
gebrauchen ich meine normale menschen
würden sich jetzt wahrscheinlich die
anleitung durchlesen und irgendwie
gucken wie man was wir zusammen baut und
welchen stockmann vielleicht nicht
anfassen sollte aber ich meine wo habe
ich eigentlich hin geworden ich weiß
nicht ob das wirklich eine gute video
idee ist oder ob ihr euch jetzt denkt
halt doch einfach dein maul
da waren auch so komische blätterwald
blog darauf kann man malen oder so luca
- shop.de
ich komme mit gerade auch noch nicht so
richtig klar wisst ihr was fakt ist ich
mache jetzt einfach auf
ich krieg dich auf was ist dass die
anleitung meint ich soll das hier rein
drehen und dann kann ich das gegen die
rausziehen entgegen ich habe das erste
ding aufgemacht und freunde ich habe
wirklich keinen bock auf ihn nach
anleitung oder so ich tippe dass jetzt
einfach mal hier rein hab dass ich fest
dass hier ist der erste stoff den wir
hier drin haben es steht drauf dass
gesundheitsschädlich ist bei
verschlucken verursacht schwere
augenreizungen fordert hautreizungen
sehr giftig für wasserorganismen seinem
kupfer sulfat gemischt was ich damit
jetzt genau machen kann weiß ich nicht
denn ich jetzt wasser rein verpasst
man macht doch was explodiert oder so
keine ahnung was ist denn das für ein
sicherheitsschlüssel man sie nicht ab
ich dachte ich sterbe ähnliche
explosionen oder irgendwie sowas aber
ich kriege immer diese kette von
sicherheit schüssel weg das mit dem
sicherheitsschlüssel irgendwie nicht so
ganz funktioniert müssen jetzt andere
mittel herhalten ein paar sekunden
später ich habe jetzt noch eine schale
geholt wo wir gleich flüssigkeiten
reinpacken kann dann ein messer ein
anderes messer auch noch eine schere
kinder macht das bitte nicht zu hause
das ist nicht so wie es gemacht werden
soll das kam spritzen auch immer die
sicher auch immer die sicherheits brille
aufsetzen der sich halt wirklich nicht
luca chemiker boy oder so ne aber das
hier funktioniert tatsächlich in grün
geworden ich habe aber irgendwie auch
gerade mehr das gefühl dass ich ach du
heilige scheiße was ist das denn
weinsäure alter was tut was soll ich
denn mit weinsäure machen das gefäß der
weinsäure hoffentlich packt das jetzt
auch einfach mal so ein bisschen hier
rein könnt ihr jetzt irgendwie
verursacht schwere augenreizungen nach
gebrauch händen und ich war schon
schutzhandschuhe tragen da steht schon
schuhe tragen falls sie das lesen können
und ich naja bei kontakt mit der haut
einige minuten lang mit wasser will
haltet eure mama lilly heute bist jetzt
so schlimme ist also ich weiß nicht was
ich machen soll ich das jetzt einfach
mal komplett hier rein und jetzt haben
wir hier ein gemisch aus seife und blaue
ding was ich packe jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen weinsäure auf den roten löffel
drauf und ich will jetzt einfach mal
sehen was passiert wenn ich das ganze
anzünde stimmt auf jeden fall
ich weiß ja dass die weinsäure ist oder
das plastik was ich dann angezündet
haben aber ich stehe auf jeden fall
ungemein alter was wir ja auch noch
haben ist ausbluten des universal
indikator papier diesen gegenstand bitte
behutsam mit dem dafür vorgesehenen
sicherheit
sie öffnen sodass ist offen und wenn ich
das jetzt mal raus nehme sehen wir schon
ich kriege es gar nicht raus es ist ein
ganz normaler streifen papier ja gut ist
halt einfach ein brennendes papier jetzt
zweimal auf hierzu bremste kam auf
universal papier ist sicher die hälfte
von dem spektakulären vorgestellt aber
ich hoffe ich kann das video trotzdem
irgendwie andere weise unterhaltsam
gestalten wir führen jetzt ein wenig von
der flüssigkeit in einen in den anderen
dies relativ schnell sehr folge große
packen wir in den dafür vorgesehenen
behälter und zündete es an
das geht nicht wir haben auch noch
kalium hacks asian overath
also warum nennt man so einen stoff
nicht einfach kämen gesundheitsschädlich
bei verschlucken hautkontakt einatmen
hände warum immer das mit händen wenn
dann bin ich in handschutz fragen sollen
geht mir doch ein kleiner diesel ist in
dieser verdammte sicherheitsschlüssel
imam worden wer braucht ein
sicherheitsschlüssel noch einmal
funktioniert verdammte kacke der
baukasten ist bei allem respekt den
ultra coolen macker damit echt coole
sachen machen aber ihnen wie komme ich
damit einfach klar mein gott ich hab
schon wieder kaputt gemacht wir nehmen
jetzt unsere prinzipien mit einer
flüssigkeit drin und schicken ihn die
flüssigkeit etwas von anderen flüssen
erfolg es hat die farbe verändert das
ist wirklich das erste mal gerade das
was passiert ist wo ich sage was sie
doch nie schokopudding die flüssigkeit
drin ist blau und ich habe doch dieses
weiße pulver ein getan und es ist
einfach schwarz geworden ich schütte das
jetzt mal in die schale gut
jetzt kommt nicht raus kann ich das
nicht irgendwie jeder dafür aus wie
kaninchen kühnel mit irgendeiner blaue
flüssigkeit
hackl da drin das riecht so wie wenn man
so wie ich wünschte ich könnte
irgendwelche gerüchte hier irgendwie an
euch weitergeben weil es ist gerade im
oktober autor ich gehe mit den händen
mit den ich in der weinsäure wagen
meiner haare auch richtig gut ist dass
ich gerade als ich sie in meiner
aufgepustet habe dann den ballon klebt
auch noch so ein bisschen weinsäure und
auf der weinsäure steht drauf dass man
es nicht essen soll
ich hoffe demnächst kommen noch videos
auf einem kanal der nächste stopp wir
uns anschauen werden ist natrium
karbonat ich glaube nach zwei kamerad
ist in wasser ich präsentiere das ist
übrigens noch mal weißes pulver blaues
getränke weißes pulver rein und ihr seht
schon getränk wirtschaftsfonds coca cola
also ich mach mich bei vielen videos zum
affen aber ich glaube das ist das erste
video wo es bei mir echt gesundheitliche
auswirkungen haben wir schritte jetzt
ein fachmann atrium karbonat in diese
braune passte dass wir hier schon hatten
und hört ihr das ist mal komplett rein
und halte das jetzt ans mikro hört sie
haben die sprudelnde kohlensäure dazu
finde ich jetzt noch ein bisschen wasser
in unseren getränken einig sieht
wirklich aus wie cola verdammte scheiße
ich will jetzt einfach nur trinken
da hätte man auf das echt nicht zu nah
an die nase halten und was ist das ihr
würde brille diebe schlägt die ganze
zeit freunde ich habe ja gerade dieses
weiße pulver in diese komische schale
hier getragen und ich meine dieses
getränke wurde ja dann irgendwie schwarz
aber das hier wird einfach lila grün
weiß was passiert wenn ich das anzünden
daran merkt man dass ich kein raucher
bin ich mein so trägt wie das video zu
beginn waren ja jetzt gerade bin ich
echt komplett überzeugt ist diese lücke
des man berührt das einmal so ein
bisschen oben und alles ist irgendwie am
globalen wieder runter tag was hab ich
kreiert alter kinder wenn ihr das selber
macht dann setzte sicher
die brille auf und nehmen vor allem auch
sicherheits handschuhe also wurde zwar
gesagt die sind da nicht drin und ich
soll mir doch gefälligst welche holen
aber ja habe ich jetzt nicht über die
sicherheits brille ist gut gar keine
frage aber vielleicht sollte man durch
eine sicherheits brille was sie sehen
weil dies irgendwie total beschlagen
immer und jetzt sehe ich auch einmal
wieder alle der nächste stoff den wir
eröffnen das eisensulfat also
eisensulfat sieht ein bisschen so aus
wie mondsteine kanada freuen
wir fügen der schale jetzt einfach mal
ein ganz kleines körnchen alten sulfat
hinzu hochalpen ist jetzt alle annehmen
jetzt auch mal wieder so ein bisschen
von dieser cola hier und packen das auch
mal mit dazu und werde das essen sollen
addict formieren raus und leben
gesponsert haben mich noch ein bisschen
kalium heck jetzt haben wir nichts mehr
auch die cdu spitze
das ist gerade ausbau diese spinne das
so kramp karrenbauer rausgefallen merzig
passiert wirklich schreibtisch ich kann
mir sogar hiervon was in die parteien
ziehen und dann die pipette einfach in
so eine halterung einpacken
klappt doch nicht so ganz und dann kann
ich die pipette umdrehen
ich möchte ich will ultra gern dieses
schlumpf pulver einfach mal alles hier
reinpacken aber jetzt sieht aus wie
scheiße was passiert wenn ich jetzt auf
wasser einschnitte natürlich blond ist
wieder fast explodiert auch einfach mal
warum guckt euch dieses video an also
versteht es nicht falsch also das finde
ich cool aber also dass sie so fassbar
ungesund aus was ist das für eine scheiß
flüssigkeit davon habe ich habe ich
meine ganzen schule sache mit
irgendeiner für
sich kein übergossen und dann angezündet
und genau so sah das dann auch aus
abitur bist du da drin jeden wurf der
nächste stoff den wir hier haben ist
rami ich weiß nicht was rami sein soll
oder ray oder einfach in tieringen es
ist ein draht also bei allem respekt es
ist ein es ist ein ganz kleiner trat
übrigens das hier ist weinsäure an
meinen fingern diese
gesundheitsschädlicher ich weiß was man
damit keine witze machen sollte aber
also wenn ich sterbe beim video
aufnehmen von einem chemiebaukasten von
galileo für meinen youtube kanal an dass
wir in schönheit und liefert es war sehr
schön mit die arbeit muss jetzt leider
ist einfach noch immer wir haben
eigentlich alle stoffe irgendwie
aufgebraucht ich habe hier noch
luftballons sprecherin nicht aufgeblasen
kamen den baukasten oder warum steht die
chance denn jetzt so sehr wir haben ja
auch noch irgendwann batterie chips fun
fact ich starte gerade die dritte
aufnahme welchen der oder teils bei 65
minuten bin ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht mehr was ich jetzt noch machen
könnte ich könnte rein theoretisch noch
mal den drahtigen wie anzünden aber ich
weiß auch nicht ob das irgendwie freunde
ich will dass am liebsten gerade alles
irgendwie müll schmeißen
deswegen sage ich an dieser stelle danke
fürs zuschauen meine damen herren
vielleicht konnte ich euch mit dem video
in irgendeiner form erhalten die sache
ist halt das relativ schwer war
irgendwas jetzt davon zu machen weil ich
auch gerade auf dem kittel sitze etwas
schwer
nachher zu machen was cool ist außer ich
hätte mir dieser anleitung hier
durchgelesen aber hey freunde die ist 54
seiten landen wenn ihr damit spaß haben
wollte ich dachte das wird sowie aber da
waren gar nicht solche flüssigkeiten
berichte ich hätte vielleicht
tatsächlich mal einfach irgend welche
flüssigkeiten mit wasser vermischen soll
dass er vielleicht gewesen
trotzdem hoffe ich dass ich das video
vielleicht dinge gefallen hat er das
glas getan habe freue ich mich über eine
bewertung ich bin total fertig wir sehen
uns im nächsten video wieder und zum
abendessen hess ich dann diesen grünen
pott blau mit draht und es stinkt wie
die hölle